khan academy is most known for our
library of over 2000 videos covering
everything from basic edition all the
way to college level math and science
but i want to cover in this video is the
software piece of khan academy which we
think is at least as significant as the
video piece so if you click on do
exercises on the khan academy right here
this is the first thing that a student
will see this thing on the right right
here this is our knowledge map and this
shows all of the different concepts that
we have exercises on so each of these
stars is a different concept and then
they're just listed in order over here
this right here if it's green it's a
suggested exercise it also says all of
the exercises and the recent ones if you
need a review exercise it'll tell you
it'll tell you what you're proficient in
and the general paradigm is you start
every student at one plus one equals two
let me click over there and show you
what this module looks like so this is
basic addition it's the most basic
mathematics if you know how to do it you
literally just type in the answer and
it will build your streak the paradigm
is is that this will generate an
infinite number of problems for you
their computer generated until you get
10 in a row so make sure that you have
no gaps in your knowledge if you don't
know how to do this you could watch the
khan academy video from our library or
if you don't know how to do that
particular problem you can always click
i'd like a hint and it gives you the
actual steps and all of this is in a a
game like framework you have energy
points here which are the points that
keep track of how much effort you put in
and they're there to try to motivate
students to work on
what will challenge them or what will
improve their learning the most there's
also a bunch of badges and things that
students can get as well we'll talk
about that in a second
just to get a sense of the scope of the
knowledge map so the this is all these
are all of the nodes and i could keep
scrolling here but once you get ten in a
row on level one edition then it will
recommend that you do level two edition
mult the next the first level of
multiplication and then level one
subtraction so this these lines show the
dependencies and so you can keep moving
up and up and let me zoom out a little
bit so we can get a better appreciation
for everything and just so you get a
sense of the type of modules that there
are there are things in geometry like
this pythagorean theorem module if you
know how to solve what they're asking
for you can just put the answer in if
you don't know how to solve it you can
say i'd like a hint and you can get the
actual hints
you can get the actual hints for that
type of problem now if you have no clue
of how to do it you can watch the videos
for that type of problem and these are
the related videos right over here let
me show you maybe one more module just
so that we get a sense of the scope over
here so you have modules like this which
are algebra modules if you know how to
do it if you know how to solve for x
type select the answer and there are
other types of there's free answer and
things like that as well
if you don't know how to do it it will
give you the steps for that exact
problem and once again there's an
infinite number of problems it will give
you as many as you need until you can
show your proficient by doing 10 in a
row so the paradigm is ki the student
really just works at their own pace and
really gets motivated through the points
and the game mechanics to go as far as
they can and right now our knowledge map
covers everything from very basic
mathematics from that basic edition well
into high school level mathematics most
of algebra and algebra ii and already a
good amount of trigonometry and
precalculus and even a little bit of
calculus so that's just the what a
student would do on a regular basis but
next i want to show you
kind of the data that the student can
see on him or herself and also what a
teacher or parent can see on the student
so both that this view can be viewed
either by the student or by a mentor a
parent or a teacher so this just shows
the activity over the last few days this
kind of a light green color that shows
the time spent the height is the time
spent on videos on that day sorry the
time the time spent on exercises on that
day and the navy blue shows the time
spent on videos and these show this is
the highest badge achieved and this is
proficiency achieved that day when you
scroll on top of it it gives you more
detail on what happened on that day you
see right here on february 8 2011
4625 energy points 19 total minutes
spent on videos it shows which videos 19
minutes spent on exercises shows the
exercises and it tells the achievements
that the student has achieved now you
can get this over at any time duration
this is the student over the last 30
days
this is actually from a trial we're
doing out here in northern california
where the students are doing this as
part of their classroom so they're doing
it both at home and at night so this is
over the last 30 days you can also see
what the student did yesterday and you
can see it by hour so you can get pretty
granular detail and once again when you
scroll over you see the detail this is
these are the badges that a student
earns and they get more prestigious as
you go to the left your meteorite badges
are pretty easy to get black hole badges
are super hard to get sun badges are
quite hard to get but if we just look at
this students moon badges these are the
ones that they've
these are the badges that he or she has
earned and then here are the possible
badges and these are things that we want
to motivate students to do so if you
become a apprentice arithmetician if you
get proficiency in these modules you can
go transonic which means doing problems
very quickly getting a streak very
quickly on an exercise you can um you
can show that you're persistent any type
of trait that we think are positive
we've been creating badging mechanisms
for
and so there's obviously other badges
earth badges are even more prestigious
sun badges all of the rest once again
all this is available it's free you just
have to log in with the google or
facebook id and we're going to extend
that to other types of ways to log in
and so you could see this just the
activity you can also see focus which is
a read of what the student has been up
to so if you're a parent or a teacher
say hey you know what has
my child been up to and this outer
circle over here shows
the mix of exercises the student has
worked on and if you scroll over it
gives more detail the inner circle shows
the mix of videos and once again it
gives detail by video and you can do it
over different time durations as well
and then you can click on any one of
these you can click on any one of these
to get more detail so in simplifying
radicals students spent 52 minutes in
the last 30 days on this did 89 total
problems 55 correct without a hint but
if you want more granular data and this
is about as granular as you can get you
can actually see all of the problems
that the student has done
all of them so this is this is 50 this
is the 55th problem that the student did
got it wrong
then watched then watched the video and
got some hints then got and the red
means wrong blue means right the height
of the bar means how long it took them
in seconds so they watched a video got
hint got a few right but then started to
get some wrong watch the video again
slowly kind of kind of ironed out the
deficiencies that they would have and
eventually what they were able to get
they were able to get 10 in a row and if
a teacher or student or a parent wants
to know exactly which problem they got
wrong or right you can literally just
click on that bar and you will see the
exact problem that the student got wrong
and you can show me next hint and it'll
actually give you the steps of how to
solve it if you want a mentor or tutor
that exact student and then let me show
you let me show you some of the other
reports that you can get so i showed you
focus there's also the exercise progress
report which is just a read of
completion from a student's point of
view it's kind of another way of looking
at the knowledge map
green means the student is proficient in
it blue means that they are working on
it but everything seems to be okay and
red means they're working on it but they
are probably stuck and you can scroll
over it to get a little bit more detail
once again if you click on it you get
granular data you can also get the
progress over time
so this is literally just a count of how
many modules the student has completed
over time so this is days on the site
this is modules completed and you can
scroll over any of these dots and you
can see which module was completed at
which date so that's from the student's
point of view and we're constantly
adding
more views on the student now from a
teacher point of view and this is being
used in a trial this is data from an
actual live trial
teachers get live data on all of the
students in their class so this is a
report from yesterday for from our live
trial and this shows each bar here is a
different student and it shows where
where and what they worked on so light
blue shows what they worked on in the
classroom dark blue shows on what shows
what they worked on at home and shows it
shows exactly what they were up to when
you scroll there and exactly when they
worked so the students from 6 15 to 7 20
spent 65 minutes doing these two
exercises this student over here when
they went home they watched those two
videos and they did those three
exercises in the classroom this is what
they were up to but the paradigm here
and this is useful by itself is for a
student to walk in every day
and they look at a dashboard that shows
where every student is in the class and
the paradigm is
the students who are you know they're
going to be at all different levels so
let me make it clear so this is a
dashboard these are the students right
over here i blanked them out for privacy
reasons
but each row here is a student each
column here is a different concept one
of those stars that you saw in the
knowledge map green means that the
student is proficient already in that
concept let me scroll to the right blue
means that they're working on it but no
cause for concern and then red means
red means that they are probably stuck
so the paradigm for the teacher is is
intervene only when a student is stuck
and that intervention might be a direct
intervention take these two kids aside
and work on multiplying decimals or
there's one student in particular is
having trouble with multiplying decimals
or even better why you take some of
these students here that are already
proficient and pair them up with the
student
first so this is just a a and then we
have other reports there's even a
real-time dashboard of what what exactly
is going on in the classroom in real
time the class isn't going on right now
so i can't show you that dashboard but
we're constantly adding new reports to
really facilitate this paradigm of every
kid learning at their own pace having a
ton of data so that the teacher and the
parent can really leverage their time
optimally to really
focus on students weak points